what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
death boy the suicidal fry-cook left a
message with the following i've watched
about four or five of your videos so far
and i'd really like to get your take on
what a good recommended reading order
and/or timeline to read especially if i
read six one six where do you think is a
good place to start and pay attention to
this is a fantastic question and in this
video we're going to be answering it
so before we get too far into this video
there are a couple things that we need
to go over the first is that we're only
going to be focusing on four characters
in this video the first is the
Incredible Hulk after that is Thor
followed by Captain America and Iron Man
and the reason why I chose these
characters is because I think there's
really kind of this surge in interest in
Marvel Comics going on right now but I
think it's a direct result of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and I think a lot of
people who were inclined to look at
Marvel comics are probably inclined to
look at these characters and so I
figured that if we're going to do a back
story or at least a video on how on
which comics to read and where to kind
of go to then I figured we'd do one with
characters that people are most
interested in and then kind of go from
there in later videos what we're also
going to do is we're going to talk about
some anthologies that Marvel had
released or that had been released by
Atlas comics the precursor to Marvel
Comics before Marvel Comics became what
it is today
now these anthologies were pretty
interesting they were an amalgamation of
sci-fi and horror stories and of course
they were called tales of suspense
strange tales journey into mystery and
tales to astonish now this is where you
saw a lot of Marvel characters and in
fact the Marvel characters that were
going to be talking about gaining their
foothold in the Marvel Comics universe
because it wasn't really feasible for
Marvel comics to take a character like
Iron Man and to just give him his own
story with no idea whether or not he was
going to be popular we saw that fail
with the Incredible Hulk we saw that
fail with the first run of the x-men and
so Marvel really kind of had to take the
stands that it needed to be done in a
way to where they could create a
character that if it failed it wouldn't
be a huge financial loss you wouldn't
have these writers and artists who could
have been focusing on already
established characters and already
established teams rather than taking a
break and focusing on something new that
was eventually going to fail so starting
with the Incredible Hulk The Incredible
Hulk of course in the very beginning had
his own storyline his own comic this
were this was the Incredible Hulk issues
number one through six and as we discuss
in the Incredible Hulk videos there were
a few things going on here of course at
the time in the United States you had
this real big social upheaval with
regards to rates you had different races
being viewed differently now than they
had been before and in addition to
Marvel creating a new lineup of the
x-men in giant-size x-men
number 75 that was a multicultural group
The Incredible Hulk also reflected this
change but in a different way The
Incredible Hulk was gray when he first
appeared and the reason why he was grey
was because Marvel wanted to introduce a
character that was racial neutral they
didn't want it to appear as though they
favored one race over another now
issues number one through six is when
you get the backstory of The Incredible
Hulk so if you feel like you're a little
hazy in terms of the backstory or if you
simply just want the comic book version
of the backstory then these are the
issues that I would read now if what
you're looking for is the current
representation of the Incredible Hulk
that is to say the Incredible Hulk
that's green that we all know and love
then you'd want to start with tales to
astonish number 59 and this is where the
Incredible Hulk is brought back after
his six run issue is canceled we see him
fighting people like the thing we also
see him up here in other comic books the
amazing spider-man the Fantastic Four
the first run of the original x-men this
is the Incredible Hulk that I think most
of you will probably find pretty
interesting and I think this is probably
the point that you would want to start
from because it would give you an idea
the Incredible Hulk that that you know
and you love journey into mystery and
Thor are really kind of interesting
because the two really go hand in hand
again journey into mystery was one of
these sci-fi horror anthologies but once
Thor was introduced to journey into
mystery with issue number 83 it really
kind of became Thor's own personal comic
and so if you're looking to get into the
Thor comics if you're looking to read on
the Thor comics then journey into
mystery number 83 is where you're going
to want to start simply because of the
fact that Thor's stories can be a little
convoluted but with issue number 83 of
journey into mystery going forward into
the actual Thor proper comics this is
going to give you the entire story
you're going to learn about the origins
of Thor you're going to learn about how
Thor is not actually immortal but how
they have to consume some kind of fruit
I can't afford it is but they have to
consume some fruit every few thousand
years in order to maintain their age and
maintain their vitality this is where
you'll be introduced to characters like
Jane Foster and and so on and so forth
with Captain America Captain America is
a little different here I would not
suggest side skirting any of the comics
that Captain America is
and here's why Captain America first
appeared around 1941 I think in Captain
America Comics number one and this was
Captain America fighting Adolf Hitler
and of course this ran for 78 issues but
the reason why I say not to side skirt
this despite the fact that it has
nothing to do with the current version
of Captain America is because there's a
sort of posterity that goes along with
knowing about Captain America there's a
sort of maybe it's at a personal
satisfaction of mine at the very least
that goes along with knowing that I know
the entire story of Captain America now
if you choose not to take this road if
you decide that this isn't the road for
you and all you want to do is focus on
the current version of Captain America
then you'll want to start with tales of
suspense issue number 58 and what
happened here is that Marvel was
experimenting and kind of toying with
the idea of bringing Captain America
back and so they simply asked the
audience and what they did is they had a
story with Johnny Storm who was
supposedly fighting
Captain America who was a villain at the
end of the comic we learned that it's
not actually Captain America but it is a
villain named Acrobat who is dressed up
as Captain America and at the end of the
comic Marvel asked the reader do you
want to see Captain America return and
for the most part that's a resounding
yes now Captain America officially
appears for the first time since World
War Two in comic books during Avengers
number four and this is where you learn
the entire story of what happened
between World War two and Captain
America's reappearance this is when you
learned about how he was fighting and
flying a drone plane drone plane crashed
he was frozen in a block of ice for
decades and finally discovered from
there he really kind of picks up in
tales of suspense number 59 and this
runs until issue 99 after issue 99 tales
of suspense goes away and it becomes
Captain America's comic and that's why
if you were to go and look up the first
Captain America Solo comics its World
War 2 it would say Captain America
number 100 it's not a misprint it's not
a typo Marvel simply just continued the
numerical order of the comic books after
the tales of suspense went away so
Ironman I would say it's probably the
most popular character in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe simply because Robert
Downey jr. has betrayed him in such an
amazing way
captain I'm sorry Ironman first appeared
in tales of suspense issue number 39 and
much like Captain America Iron Man was a
depiction of what was perceived to be
the righteous mind of the United States
fighting against some sort of adversary
in this instance communism now I don't
know if Iron Man was fighting against
the Communist leader Chiang kai-shek and
Vietnam per se but I do know that Iron
Man was fighting against Vietnamese
communists now this ran for about 60
issues it ran until tales of suspense
number 99 and for the most part these 60
issues really only deal with iron man
fighting communism to a degree you see
some other things but what you'll see
over the course of these issues is iron
men really kind of coming into his own
so for the sake of understanding iron
man as he progresses and eventually gets
his own title series and iron man number
one I would suggest going back and
reading tales of suspense number thirty
nine through 99 just so you can have a
well-rounded view of iron man as a whole
now once it gets an Iron Man number one
this is when you start seeing a lot of
the characters that you've seen so far
you see Justin Hammer you see just a
James Rhodes you see pardon me you see
whiplash you see who else do you see in
there I came in roughed up my head but
you see a lot of the characters and a
lot of the villains that you've seen in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so far
returning to Iron Man you see them in
these comics and of course it runs for
four hundred some-odd issues I think
with that being said I'm gonna go ahead
and us video to an end I hope it was
helpful if it was let me know and I will
catch you guys later peace